>> Male Presenter: Hi everyone, and thanks
again for coming to another
authors at Google event here in the San Francisco
office.
Today we are very pleased to have Dan and
Corey join us. They are the cofounders of
the record setter.com.
Dan has actually come back to San Francisco
[inaudible] and he's a
world record fanatic for now since the age
of 10. And proudest
to have set the 11 RecordSetter world records.
Less proud however that ten of them
have been beat. Former advertising exec who
created two Super Bowls, Dan now
resides over in Brooklyn, but we won't hold
that against him. Corey is an entrepreneur
who's
been working in web development since 1967.
And probably holds the, 1967, Actually
1867. 1997. And probably holds the world record
for the
longest time to watch Amazing Horse while
working.
You'll hear about that hopefully today. [laughter]
Corey also lives in New York City. They're
here to talk about RecordSetter which is a
new book that they've come out with which
celebrates over 300 of the loudest,
longest, slowest, weirdest and coolest, and
most difficult to break records ever set.
Please
join me in welcoming Dan and Corey.
[Applause]
>> Dan: Hello, everybody. How is it going?
Can you hear us
at the back? Allrighty. [giggling] My name
is Dan. This is
Corey. Thank you Nick for having us here and
thanks
to all of you for coming. So we're going to
be talking
about world records. I always like to say
this project
began when I was 10 and got my first Guinness
Book of
world records and just fell in love with the
concept of
World Records and fell in love with this whole
concept of world records. It was just this
amazing book that you could pore
through and see all these amazing people around
the
world. I just love this sentiment of billions
of people
on this planet. I love the idea that, you
know, these
people were actually the world's best; the
number one in
a particular area. So I always just said,
"You know, I
want to be a world record holder someday.”
That just
seemed like a cool thing. So I was a 10-year-old
boy. I
went off in college got a little more serious
about it and started researching setting a
Guinness world record. I
once tried to woo a girl to have a go at ravioli
eating. Because I kept looking through the
book and I
thought maybe I could be a speed eater. I
A, realize I'm
not a very fast eater and B, she was totally
unimpressed
by this. [laughter] But you know, but my love
for world records
continued and as Nick mentioned, I have a
previous
career in advertising. I was a creative working.
My
last full-time job was at Goodby Silverstein
here in San
Francisco. So I came out here in 2002 and
went out with
some friends to Burning Man Festival. Any
people
who've been? [giggling] Alright. Cool. Woo
woop! So you know went out to burning
man. Totally intrigued by it. Had my mind
totally blown
away by mass creativity. People pouring their
hearts and
soul into major projects none of which were
related with
commerce. You know, things that people love
to do and that ranged from dance and performance
and
art and music and on and on and on. So I was
just
super excited by what was happening. And after
going for
a couple of years, just felt more and more
of this desire
that I was going and taking it in but I really
wanted to
build something, that's a big part of the
Burning Man
spirit of build something and pour your own
heart and
energy and soul into the entire community
and experience.
Some friends and I had a dinner in the Tenderloin.
It's
a little Thai restaurant on the corner, I
forget the
name of it. But we just sat down all right
we need an
idea for our Burning Man camp because deadlines
are
getting close and we want to do something
awesome. A
bunch of ideas were kicked around. I brought
up my love
of world records. I was like, "Hey guys, why
don't we
create a world record theme camp. And we'll
just figure
it out and let people set Burning Man world
records.” It
was a very loose idea but finally everybody
kind of
rallied around it. We called ourselves the
Playa Book of
Records and went off to the desert. This was
in 2004, went off to the desert. Somebody
had suggested as an
homage to wild world of sports that we wear
yellow
jackets. They were not nearly as fancy as
these. These
were going off to thrift stores and going
on Ebay to find yellow
jackets. You don't see these often. They're
hard to
find even on the Internet. So we just went
off and we
just wore yellow jackets and said we're the
Playa Book of
Records, does anybody want to set a record?
And it was
just a very open brief. And people came up
and were
like, "Anything? Like it doesn't have to be
something
like Guinness recognizes? It doesn't have
to be
something you guys decide is cool or not?”
And we were like, "No, set a record we're
going to document it and we're
going to make you a world record holder."
We would see
feats , we can show you some of these videos,
we would see feats like the fastest accordion
rendition of the "Devil
Went Down to Georgia." And then a woman came
up with a
super deep inny and she set a world record
for the most
blueberries fit in a belly button. [laughter]
And then we had a guy
who came up on those spring stilts and he
did the most
consecutive back flips on stilts. And so it
was like, most balloon dogs created in one
minute.
The creativity was just pouring out of all
these people.
It's a creative community and people really
seem to enjoy
this open assignment. So our camp continued
to grow.
Like, we went back and we were there for five
years from
'04 until '08. And you know, then we standard
to create
leader boards. And so, we would have people
see the
other world records that existed. And now
you've got
people creating records. And you've got other
people
saying "Wait a sec, like the world record
for most
quarters fit in a nose is only 3.? Like get
me some records.
I want to beat that record." And so, that
starts getting
competitive. You know, then we would come
back the next
year and people would run off and say like
"Where's the
leader board? Do I still hold my record from
last year
because it means so much to me." And I'd be
"No dude, someone beat it.
And do you want to come back and try to win
it back?" The
competition was growing. The creativity was
blossoming.
It was wonderful to see all this happening.
During these
years it was when Wikipedia was starting to
revolutionize
the encyclopedia and people were realizing
wow there can
be something much bigger and more community
driven and
participatory than the Encyclopedia Britainica.
And with
that kind of spirit, you know as this project
grew at
Burning Man, there was, you know, the beginning
thoughts
of like wait a second why does this have to
just be in
the desert five days a week every single year?
How on
earth can this be put into the world at large
and get
everybody playing? So then I went to a summer
camp in
New Hampshire spent a week doing it with kids.
I just
wanted to try it with kids and the kids were
even more
creative and ,more outrageous than the people
at Burning Man.
It kept growing. I met Corey in 2006. I had
known his
wife from my years in advertising. She's a
photographer.
And we met here in San Francisco. They were
visiting.
We went out for dinner and then to see RATATAT
at the
Great American Music Hall. Woo woo! And basically
while
the band was playing we were just. I was all
fired up.
I had just come back from Burning Man. I knew
that
Corey. I'll let him tell about his technological
background. But I didn't really know many
people in
technology. And so, I basically spent a night.
We just
started talking about like, if and how this
thing could
go on to the Internet. So.
>> Corey: Yeah, you know and for me, it just
sort of made
perfect sense. My immediate reaction was more
about
like, you know, wait a second why do a group
of guys in
England get to decide what world records should
exist and
what ones shouldn't exist? The whole reason
the Internet
exists is for people to argue about stuff
like that. And
we have, obviously, we live in the age of
video.
That's accessible to everybody now. And we
put the two
together. And like we said, we didn't even
get to watch
the concert. We were just talking about the
idea the
whole time. So.
>> Dan: So yeah. So then Corey went back to
New York. I was
still working here in San Francisco and we
became pen
pals and started figuring out what the database
was going
to look like. Again, I'm technologically somewhat
incompetent. So Corey was the zen master and
patient zen
master as we started to build this thing together.
I
eventually quit here and I moved back to New
York for
life reasons. And but, you know, then obviously
we
started working more closely together and
went into a
shared office space. And we really boot strapped
this
thing for a couple of years. I was doing some
freelancing and advertising. Corey was working
on
another startup at the time. But we just,
it was just
like this big hobby that was just something
we knew we
wanted to put on the Internet. We didn't know
if it was
going to be. Our original aim was URDB the
universal
record database.org. So we had lots of debates
about
whether this should be a for profit or a nonprofit
or not for profit. But
we just knew we had 150 world records from
Burning Man couple dozen from the summer camp
in New Hampshire. And
we just said like, "We've got to put this
thing on the
Internet least for people to see these world
records and
hopefully we're going to be able to build
a tool for
everybody to play along and seeing world records
that
they think they can beat. Documenting themselves
on
video and up loading it.” And/or saying
"I want to create
a totally new world record myself." So we
built the thing
for a couple of years. And launched in beta
just under
three years ago at the end of 2008. And the
last three
years has been like a crazy adventure. So
we have a
short brand video about record setter which
I think will
kind of begin to fill you in on what's been
happening. Then
we can begin to tell you about the book and
tell you
about some more amazing records.
>> Corey: You know, what we need to do is
audio.
>> Dan: Mm hmm.
>> Corey: Will this audio work do you think?
>Nick: Yeah.
>> Corey: Plug that in? Cool.
Sounds like it's going to work.
>> [Video plays. Electronic music].
>> Dan: All right. So yeah. That's, that in
a nutshell is
what we're building. So I don't know if you
have had a
chance to see the website, but it really is
just, we
have over 10,000 records now, primarily video.
And
we're really just trying to continue to lower
the bar for
setting a world record. And changing them
from something
you read about in a book that comes out once
a year to
something that you can participate in and,
you know,
everybody from young kids to groups to, you
know,
companies and beyond can get involved with.
So we were
laughing this morning that, you know, we're
a digital
company and record setter.com is the core
of what we're
building and yet it's this book that gets
us invited to
come and speak at Google. [laughter] So. We
can.
>> Corey: Do you want to talk about where
the book came from and--
>> Dan: Sure. Yeah, so as this thing grew.
I mean, we've
had, you know, we're still a very small team.
We only
have 7 people in New York City. We have some
funding.
We can happily answer questions about the
business side.
Happy to talk about any side of the company
that you'd
like. Thanks to some appearances on Jimmy
Fallon and other live events and so forth
we talk to some book
publishers and teamed up with a company called
Workmen
who are awesome and spent the last couple
of years
building this book. So it was a really interesting
challenge. You know, I mean people talk about
like will
Wikipedia ever release a book? And it was
kind of a
similar challenge with how do you, with thousands
of
records choose what's the best stuff and does
it make
sense to make a book? I mean, a lot of interesting
questions
that we had to ask because we were producing
this. But,
you know, we felt ultimately that print still
is alive.
And this, you know, we've been on tour across
the country
right now. And we're seeing like, especially
kids and
teenagers. And people in their 20s, 30s, and
40s as
well but really still a lot of reading books
of world
records. So we felt it still made sense for
us to
actually put out a print book. And we're going
to be
making this a series and getting it into school
classrooms and so forth. We really tried to
rethink what
a book of world records is. You know, obviously
we love
the Guinness book and have seen it for years,
but we
wanted to make something that wasn't just
a book you
would read, but it was actually filled with
tips on how
to set world records yourselves. And then,
there's
hundreds of these records begging to be set.
We'll get
into some of our favorite records, but I just
flipped
open this page and a record begging to be
set is the
fastest time to Google every member of Nsync.
So if
everybody in this room would like to set a
world record
this weekend, document yourself on video Googling
every
member of Nsync and we'll document it on our
videos for
other Nsync aficionados to challenge.
>> Corey: Google aficionados.
>> Dan: Google aficionados.
The book is filled with a
lot of world records. I think you guys are
getting the
spirit that we're much more open than any
other world
record organization. We'd like to try to not
judge
people's categories. Our very simple rules
are that your feat
has to be quantifiable, breakable and you
have to provide sufficient
media evidence. Because we were coming to
Google, we
pulled up the most medical symptoms Googled
in 30
seconds. Biana Fay, this is a woman in Brooklyn.
She describes
herself as a low-grade hypochondriac who delights
in
Googling minor bodily sensations after scaring
herself
they might be the first sings of a serious
illness. Years
of freaking out about suspected malignant
moles that
happened to be dropped flakes of chocolate,
true story, gave her the
confidence to set this record. Perfectly healthy
as she
prepared to type in a litany of symptoms from
quote "Funny poops to itchy ankles." She took
a
minute to reassure all viewers with words
of calm. If
any of these things are happening to you,
just know
that I've been through them and am totally
fine. So Biana Googled 7 symptoms in 30
Seconds and we have criteria like, we definitely
want to create legitimate rules that people
have to follow.
So you must use Google to perform the searches.
You may
not use Google's autocomplete features. Anybody
in the
room working on the autocomplete project?
And search queries must
refer to a medical symptom or complaint. So
if we have any
hypochondriacs here who would like to have
a go at beating that record. I
person little think that's kinda a beatable
one.
>> Corey: Yup.
>> Dan: Yeah. You want to
choose a favorite?
>> Corey: Yeah, well we have a we did a project
with Weiden+Kennedy up in
Portland and they set an amazing record. I
have to find
the exact language, but the longest office
chair chain
pulled by a motorcycle. So they have a motorcycle,
a bunch
of office chairs, [laughter] pulled that down
the street out of
Portland. And then the most bizarre thing
happened at
the end. As they were preparing to do their
record, somebody
noticed then quarter back Joey Herrington
at the piano
store across the street. They invited him
to join their
record and the last chair is filled with Joey
Herrington playing a keyboard has they're
pulling down
the street pulled by a motorcycle.[laughter]
It's amazing.
>> Dan: And what's so interesting we see all
these records
like this. That's an awesome outrageous feat.
That's
not ever going to become competitive. While
that record
still stands that this inspired people at
to set a record
for the longest office chair train pulled
by a golf cart.
They were going to try to beat the record
but they
weren't allowed to bring a motorcycle into
a studio so
they tweaked it with a golf cart. And then
a small town
in Nova Scotia, Canada. People love beating
Jimmy
Fallen's record so they tried to take down
the record.
So they beat his record and pulled more office
chairs
behind a golf cart. And you know, the competitive
element I think the something that we get
really excited
about. Sometimes people will say, "are you
guys just
have that sort of youthful spirit of everybody
do something
and we're going to give everybody a gold medal.”
That's
certainly that's part of the spirit. We recognize
holding a world
record boost in self-esteem and a feeling
of achievement
that comes from that. But we don't want to
just be a
feel good thing. And we love competition.
Nick
mentioned I've set a dozen records and they've
actually
all been beaten now. [laughter] Because I'm
the president of the
company and you know when I put up a new record
it will
get taken down. The first time it happened
to me it was
a very surreal experience. I had set at Burning
Man the world record for the
most times whistling happy birthday in one
minute. And
we launched the site and we had the video
and one day a
submission came in from one teenage jerk from
San Diego
who had fit in one more happy birthday rendition.
It's almost like somebody is covering your
song.
It's really magical to watch these people
create these
really long tail record categories and then
watch them
evolve into something. You may have seen on
the front of
the book. We have this guy here. This is one
of the
first submissions we ever got at record setter.
It came in
from Australia guy named Daniel Fowler. He
set a world record for the most giraffe tattoos
on a
shoulder and he sent us in a photo of him
with one giraffe. And he said like, "Alright.
You said that your rules are quantifiable,
breakable media
evidence. This is all of that. It's one."
We laugh but we're also
like he gets the spirit of this. This is a
total
experiment. It's an ongoing work in progress.
And he
started the bar somewhere. And we thought
that record
was just going to sit. And then a, it goes
back to San
Diego -- a radio station in San Diego. They
started
doing RecordSetter world record Wednesdays.
And one
morning they said, "Okay, everybody there's
this record
held by this guy in Australia named Daniel
Fowler who has one giraffe tattoos
on his shoulder and we've brought in a local
tattoo artist and we'll provide free tattoo
to any
listener whos willing to come in and get at
least two giraffe tattooed
on their shoulder. God bless San Diego. Like
about a half
a dozen listeners called up. Me, me, free
tattoo, like I
got nothing going on today. And this guy named
Mike
McDonalds, he took the day off of work. His
girlfriend
was kind of ticked off. And he got three giraffes
tattooed on his shoulder. So then obviously
the guy in
Australia, Daniel Fowler, had his mind blown
like what's going on here?
I just did this as kind of a joke and now
I've spurred
on. To us we always say that was a day for
better and
for worse this thing is working because people
are
competing against each other in all these
totally new
categories. Two months later I came into our
office in
New York and like everybody was like all giddy
and I was
like what's going on what's going on? And
it turned out
Daniel Fowler the original guy in Australia
who had one
giraffe tattoo had gone out and he got three
more
giraffe tattoos. And sent us, you can see
him on the cover. He could not have been
more proud of the fact. It's the most cocky
look I think
I've ever seen a human being give. We were
just down in
San Diego and Mike McDonald is still like
planning to
take this record back. [laughter] But, you
know, we also have
and so we have like, like we're so open. So
we don't
want to just be ironic records. We don't want
to just be
stupid records. Like we have, we've just are
discovering all these communities of people
that never
really fit into the Guinness box. Ranging
from like a
ski ball tournament that love, that we would
recognize
all of their feats as world records. Most
balls rolled
in 30 seconds or whatever. We have these pushup
champions around the world who are using our
platform now
and competing in categories like the most
one arm pushups in one minute while
wearing a 60 pound backpack. We've worked
a bunch with
charities. I guess we can pull up the Livestrong.
>> Corey: [Inaudible]
>> Dan: We've done a partnership, there we
go. We've been doing a
partnership with Livestrong for the last year
plus.
This was a breast cancer related record. Yeah,
but most
cigarettes ripped in half and the longest
drumming marathon to raise money for
cancer research. The fastest time for young
adult cancer
survivors and their supporters to pull an
airplane 15 feet. So Livestrong
has they recognize that for years all they've
offered
are you want to get involved you have to bike
across the
country or run a marathon and they're realizing
world records
can be this new way to engage the community
and people who
may not be interested in, you know, running
a marathon or
biking 4,000 miles but want to get involved.
So we've
been working with them. This is an amazing
video. This
is one of my favorite records. Well, there's
a bunch of
good ones in here. You can see fastest time
to solve two
rubix cubes while playing Guitar Hero. You
guys want to take a peek at this?
This in this kid is a shredder. {Video plays
guitar riff music]
>> Corey: He's showing his set up there.
>> Dan: There he goes.
There he goes. [laughter] Oh yeah. [inaudible]
>> Corey: All right. We're going to skip
ahead. All right. You get the idea.
>> Dan: But are any of you
guys guitar hero experts/rubix cube solvers?
Because
this could be a fun new weekend activity.
All of these
categories, we see these things come in and
we never
know which ones are going to become competitive.
You
know, Corey talks about imagining the way
that pole vault
came to be an Olympic sport. And it probably
just began
with a couple of dudes with a stick and a
shrub and they
were just saying who can plant this thing
and fling
themselves over it. And they certainly were
not thinking
like this is someday going to be a global
competitive
sport in which there are going to be wind
rules and you
have to use the right composition for your
pole and on
and on. All of these categories if you look
at any one
as a standalone category it might seem a little
bit frivolous. But
our spirit is we'll see competition in I mean,
again like
from the giraffe tattoos to this is a great
category
also in the book. It's the most times smiling
while
listening to "Beat It." And this is became
a competitive
category. It was a girl in Philadelphia, Allison
Harris who right after Michael Jackson passed
away she
wanted to make tribute through a world record.
Because I
just think it's so charming. She made this
-- let's see.
She made this video. And then it got beaten
by another
fan. There we go. So this, let me just find
the
original one. This is the current record holder
Christa.
And she's featured in the book. Here's Allison.
[Video plays]
>> Hi. My name is Allison Harris and I'm going
to break
the record for most times smiling while listening
to
Michael Jackson's song "Beat it." [inaudible]
[Beat It by Michael Jackson plays]
[laughter]
>> Corey: It becomes an endurance challenge
for a four minute
song. Very sore facial muscles.
>> Dan: So you get the idea. Again all these
categories that
you just never know what's going to inspire
people and
where these things are going to lead to. A
category in the
book which has become kind of a global phenomenon
is the
longest high 5. So these two guys in Canada
in Toronto
who call themselves the record collection
lined up
about three miles apart in downtown Toronto
on Young
street and they made rules you have to keep
your hand up
the entire run which is not easy to keep your
arms up for this length of time and
they had cameras follow them and they just
ran towards each other and completed what
was
literally the longest high 5. And it was such
a cool
video, such a fresh idea. So simple. And then
that
inspired two guys in Australia to step up
and beat the
world record. And then, they.
>> Corey: An equally entertaining video.
>> Dan: There was some controversy in their
attempt because
one of the guys on his run gave a quick high
5 to a passerby and there was headed debate
in our community about
whether that should make it, he kind of cheated.
We let
the existing record holders agree it should
be accepted.
And then it recently got beaten by a pair
of guys in
Illinois. And now the guys in Toronto are
training. The
guys in Australia are training. To me that's
an example
of like okay this thing could turn into a
global
phenomenon. We have 10,000 of these things
and people
are creating new categories every day. Yeah,
so we're
seeing a lot of fun things..
>> Corey: Should we leave--
>>Nick: I think you have five minutes or so.
Can you take some questions?
>> Dan: Sure. And then we're going to get
you guys to set a
world record. We have one we'd like for you
guys to set.
But please, let's do a couple of questions.
>> Male #1: Are you guys for profit and do
you have companies are
you going to companies to get them involved
like at Ford or [inaudible].
>> Nick: Could you repeat the question?
>> Dan: Sure. The question was whether we're
for profit and
whether we're working with brands. The answer
is yes and
yes. A big part of our business model is built
around
not just traditional advertising but creating
branded
content. So, you know, an example we always
give is the
fastest time to open a bag of Skittles and
sort them by
color was a record category that somebody
just created
and that's been beaten five or six times.
So now we've
just done a partnership with Stride gum where
there are
100 long, lasting world records that were
pushed out to their Facebook fans two and
a half million fans. One record a day and
we got over 1,000 UGC videos in the
3-month period. So yeah, we do live events,
but the core of our brand partnerships are
digital.
>> Corey:We debated the non-profit thing for
a while and I think
I read musicbrainz.org. It think they are
The non-profit around music. And
the guy was saying he was going to try to
go to
conference and needed somebody's couch to
sleep on. We
said alright, we can't do that. We need to
be able to feed
ourselves and grow our team. So.
>> Dan: Hey Michael.
>>Male #2: [inaudible].
>> Dan: Yeah. I mean, this is definitely an
issue. Sorry --
the question is what kind of liabilities issues
we're
dealing with. It's certainly a topic that
we're very
conscious of and aware of. We have a set of
principles
that we push out to our community. The first
and biggest
one being, "don't hurt yourself; don't hurt
others; don't
hurt the environment.” We're not the hugest
fans of
consumption eating records. We say very explicitly
if
you have any concerns about the safety of
your records
please contact us first or talk with the most
responsible
person that you know. And yeah. I mean, I
think we try
to curate the site in a way that will let
some of
those records live in the corners, but we
really are
trying to create a culture based around, you
know, world
records that are truly raising the bar of
human
achievement in some manner.
>> Corey: I think there's also something to
be said for in a
lot of ways one of the main differences between
us and
Guinness is that those are Guinness' records.
That's
their body that they kind of sanctioned this
is the
record they want people to break. And I think
our model
is the records belong to the people that are
creating,
setting the records. So I mean, I think the
legal
distinction may not matter. But I think there's
something to like when you set a RecordSetter
set a
world record, that's your property. That's
your thing.
Whoever sets the new record gets to set the
rules. So
they're sort of owning how it will get shaped.
You know,
for things like the book obviously, were not
going to put in something dangerous in there
but.
>>Nick: So for time, if were going to set
a record we probably should get to it.
>> Dan: Sure. So since we're here at Google,
we look through
and we found some amazing Google records we
have. I
mentioned the medical symptoms one. We have
like most I
think e-mails in unread e-mails I think. But
this is
one that we felt we could beat. And I think
we're going
to have enough people to do it. This is the
largest group simultaneously searching the
same thing on
Google. This was.
>>Nick: [inaudible]
[cheering]
>> Dan: This was a summer camp, tech camp
in Arizona.
[Video playing in background]
>> Male in video: We're going to have the
largest group of people
searching for the same thing at the same time.
And we're
searching ID tech. So here we go. Let's all
type it in.
>> Dan: All right. So this is the category
that's been
created. Do any of you guys have a suggestion
of
something and does everybody have, I imagine
everybody
has a device of some sort? A computer or -- can
we make
sure we're going to get 17 people we can participate?
We
have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12
--
>> Corey: We can pull some people out from
the hallway.
>>Female #1: We can grab some people.
>> Dan: All right. Let's do it. Okay. And
who has are
you going to shoot that on your phone.
>> Corey: I can, yeah. Tell them they'll get
a world record holder
patch if they participate.
>> Dan: And we need a word..
>> Corey: Yeah, we need a term to search for.
What's the name of a conference room in here.
Have
any clever?
>> Dan: Hi Michael.
>> Corey: Rusty badger or something like that?
>> Male #3: There's a Dirty Harry.
>> Corey: Dirty Harry?
>> Dan: Dirty Harry. Do you guys want to do
that?
>>Nick: How about we do a word [inaudible].
>> Dan: There we go.
>> Corey: Good suggestion.
>> Corey: It's your record so [pause] I'm
ready. So what are we
searching for? The meaning of Google spelled
mathematical way?
>>Nick: Or just, yeah, search for g-o-o-g-l-e.
>> Corey: Okay..
>> Dan: So let's wait until we have, yes.
>> Corey: I'm ready to go.
>>Nick: [inaudible]
[laughter]
>> Dan: [clears throat] Okay. We're here at
Google San Francisco trying to
beat an existing record setter world record
for the most
people to simultaneously search the same thing
on Google.
The current record is held by a technology
camp in Tempe,
Arizona. This summer they got 16 people to
get together
and all Google something at the same time.
We are
now trying to get more than 16 people to get
together and Google something at the same
time. Suggestion from the room was to
Google G-o-o-g-o-l, the original word googol.
So if
everybody could prepare the word googol. And
then—
>> Corey: I will come around and confirm that
we have all searched.
>> Dan: Okay. Yes. The most people to simultaneously
Google
the same thing at the same time.
>> Corey: Everyone ready? You want to count
us down.
>> Dan: Let's make the Googling happen.
>> Corey: 3, 2, 1 -- go..
>> Dan: See? Some of these -- let's see some
screens. All
Right, googol, googol, googol, yes, this is
looking
kosher.
>>Male #4: The tensions mounting.
>> Dan: We are looking good.
[laughter] Let's see these screens.
>>Female #2: I won the world's most largest
toaster. And I.
>> Dan: Lots of screens. Oh yeah, this is
looking good.
>> Corey: Dan, you need to search, you need
to search, your 16.
>> Dan: Oh, okay, hold on.
>> Female #2: But that one was beaten recently,
actually so.
>> Dan: I'm going to add in my search. Hold
on. Ohh, ohh, okay.
G-O-O-G-O-L. And it's coming. It's coming.
>> Female # 3: But how do you know?
>> Dan: How do we know what?
>> Like what if maybe more than this group
of people have
searched Justin Bieber.
>> Dan: So there's the spirit.
>> Corey: So there's 17.
>> Woo. [applause]
>> Corey: Congratulations.
>> Dan: So we're going to wrap up, but that's
an excellent
question that was asked. How do we know this
is an
existing world record? Our general spirit
is that it's a record
until proven otherwise. So if a group of Bieber
fans see
this record and they say "Why, at Bieber fest
'09 we had 300
people Google' Justin Bieber is cute' at the
same time."
Great, give us the evidence. Submit it to
RecordSetter
and we'll recognize your feat. It's all a
work in
progress. And that's, you know, it really
is such a
pleasure that we get to make this our full-time
job now. [laughter]
Like, we couldn't be having more fun. And
we really feel
we're doing something that's interesting and
exciting and
participatory and you know ties into all the
things that
make the Internet wonderful. So thanks for
coming. And
we'll stick around if you guys have any more
questions.
>> Corey: Come get a patch. A world record
holder patch.
>> Female #3: Oh, wow.
[Applause]